oh here's a guy right here he's from
britain
coach carter how are we doing good my
name is sean i'm from the
north of scotland a place called
inverness if you don't know where that
is
uh the loch ness monster stays about
three miles that way wow
wow that's not the loch ness monster
that people are dropping into your dm's
about
so i've got a debate club for you we're
in scotland it's dinner time
do you go for that haggis neeps and ties
here where'd you go for that english
bangers and mash
that's haggis turnip and potatoes or
sausage and potatoes
let me know what you think gangang buzz
buzz right now
bangers and mash but what is haggis it's
fish
i think haggis is like goat liver or
something sheep's pluck
minced onion oatmeal suet spices salt
mixed with stock
that's a hard pass oh and it's encased
in an animal's stomach
oh crazy as it should be that's what
sausage is in though
that's true yeah so they're a bit
similar i think i'm going argus man
i'm going bangers mash yeah are you yes
okay
i love you i always have always have
there we go he's
getting it always i'll get it by the end
yeah
ooh those bangers look a little girthy
huh
it looks like my dm's
what's under it huh is that hey that's
smashed
baby that [ __ ] is fire that's what i
would eat yeah or fish and chips that's
beauty air fish and chips man that's it
um and he has mash all day for me beans
for breakfast i'm going august man
you know i'm just opening my face up by
the shoreline and just beat a bunch of
just
just toss that in there yeah yeah
um and there's different types of also
accents i know that if they have like if
you're
like real fancy you like talk like this
that's what i'm saying
they give uh jason statham [ __ ] because
yeah he
originally had the fancy accent and then
he got to be more like famous as like a
tough guy
he started using the cockney accent he
was like dude what are you doing a spot
of tea sir
you know but then they gotta have some
more yeah there you go
okay then he's gonna have it
and then uh but then if you're like that
like if you're like oh can't
my leg fell off sir my leg fell off and
i can't
you know i need something to feed my mom
you know
monsieur rose so fancy roll and that's
more like uh
yeah you're living in the street yeah oh
i can't i've got a rash on my box sir
will you scratch my back buddy you
cheeky bastard
yeah you cheeky bastard oh scratch my
back buddy
oh i'm poor what's up
my family's poor sir i'm not a proof dad
that's more of a reaper it's more of a
streak yeah it's more of a street cat
it's more hood it's a little more
thug yeah okay and the avocado shirt
really helps with it
oh thank you very much it's a nice shirt
yeah this is actually a
breakfast shirt that's from they're from
australia they sent me some stuff they
did
yeah they got it cool it's only
vegetables and fruits on their [ __ ]
no they got something they did well i
got one with a jellyfish
yep beautiful they got some good items
[Music]